I was reading three easy steps to clear histamine from your body.
That's not an article from me.
But this person says towards the end of the article it discusses how to treat histamine intolerance.
Point three says it's important to find the root cause of the histamine intolerance other than genetics.
How do you find a root cause under the genetics of my histamine intolerance?
Histamines are a driver of my breast cancer.
So we're talking about two different things.
So if a person has excess histamine in their body, there's multiple possible reasons.
Number one is that they have genetic defects so they don't clear histamine very well.
And you can't fix those genetic defects so you're just using things like corset to the other things to help pull the histamine out of your body.
Number two, you can have some inflammatory process that's causing a histamine increase.
That's what I think the author of this article is talking about is find the root cause of the histamine intolerance.
You can't find the cause of the histamine intolerance.
I think what they mean is find what's causing the histamine increase what's causing the excess histamine.
So histamine is in inflammatory marker that stimulates the immune attack in the presence of some something in your body that shouldn't be in your body.
So in the case of you have a pathogen in your body, you will stimulate a histamine attack to try to clear that out of your body.
So yeah, it's your initial immune response to a toxin to a poison to a pathogen.
If it just continues to ramp and your cells continue to make histamine, that's an issue.
Part of that has to do with genetics.
Part of that has to do with a sensitivity.
If I have, if my body has created antibodies against a toxin, let's use an example of the toxin in a mosquito bite.
I don't know the name of the toxin that the mosquito injects into you when it draws your blood out to use for whatever purposes the mosquito uses your blood for.
Whatever toxin it uses some people some people go, oh my gosh, what I get a mosquito bite, I have this huge histamine reaction and I it's like crazy and I swell up and other people like I go on the same mosquito infested territory and they don't seem to bother me at all and it can be because the mosquitoes don't necessarily land on you and light on you and bite on you because of your body chemistry.
That's a whole other story, but let's say you get just as bit as somebody else or a bump bites or you could you could extend this to Paul and you could extend this to poison ivy reaction you can extend us to other fly reactions and stuff like that.
Why are some people more intolerant to those why do they why do some people have a greater histamine reaction to those.
Currently it has can be that the that that person's body has made antibodies to that toxin and because they made antibodies that toxic every time that toxic is present they fire this huge immune reaction because they have antibodies it's no different than if I have antibodies to
gluten and glieted peptides in gluten and every time I eat gluten I fire this reaction I have this you know this inflammatory process going on in my gutted my brain in my blood stream and everything else it's because I have antibodies to that peptide of food so if I have created antibodies inadvertently to something that is a major reason why I have histamine reactions.
The other problem is is that you can't just make those antibodies go away nothing pulls those antibodies out of your body some antibodies literally will stay forever like in the case of gluten.
The added antibodies they don't tend to dissipate or if you have antibodies to other foods if you stay away from that food for a period of time pretty you know many time many of those foods the antibodies dissipate quite quickly you could do another Syrex 10 test for food antibodies and those those are gone so you don't have sensitivity so that because you stayed away from that period of time same thing if you do a Syrex.
11 or 12 test which test antibodies to chemicals in your environment and other pathogens in your environment like molded things if you clear your body of those things you're not continually exposed to those things pretty soon your those antibodies go down and down you're not going to react to that as much so that's how
If you really want to find out why I have reactions to different things I know I have histamine as a driver of my breast cancer doing a Syrex 10 doing a Syrex or to see if you have antibodies to other foods that are related to gluten the three X related to gluten and the other gluten.
Cross reactants in the Syrex or the Syrex 10 array 10 is a panel of a whole bunch of different foods I think 100 different foods are so cooked and raw to see if I have antibodies to that so if there if it's anything that has to do with exposure to foods that's increasing histamines.
Secondly you could do a Syrex 11 and a Syrex 12 that tests for do I have antibodies to pathogens do I have antibodies to chemicals in my environment if I have antibodies to those things and I am exposed to those things every time I'm exposed to those things I didn't create more histamines.
So, measuring what I should stay away from can be beneficial so you want more information on that gladly make an appointment we can figure out what test would be best to order questions about meat and histamines is uncured organic turkey breast okay to eat.
Yes so typically you could you could download the histamine list on our website you could Google a histamine list of different foods the older a food is we need if it's if it's a lunch meat and you it was you know.
We could go and now it's sitting in the grocery store now you buy it it's going to have greater histamines and if you just bought a turkey and cooked up the turkey breast and you ate it it's going to have a lot less histamines that if you leave it in the fridge for a couple more days as you eat it cold it's going to have more histamines in it so the more aged the product is it's going to have more histamines.
Organic grass fed nitrate free meat sticks like chubs okay to eat well they're going to have some more histamines in it now your histamine problem may be much less related to the amount of histamines that you're eating and more related to foods that you're eating that are creating a histamine reaction like I explained before so a person can have issues because they eat foods with a lot of histamines.
Honestly that's less of a problem unless a person's like oh my gosh I have a habit of just eating a whole you know bowl full of cashews and then a bowl full of strawberries strawberries and those are really good for me well they also have a lot of histamines in it but if that's not your case and you're eating a fairly balanced meal and you're not getting foods that are just so concentrated in histamines.
Then the reason why you might have a history to histamine issues because your bodies making histamines because you have antibodies against things that you're exposed to whether it be foodborne products or pathogens or chemicals so those are the things that you want to look at.
Sometimes when people have histamine issues they really get hung up on their diet think that that's going to solve it and disdain away from things that have histamine in it may be a little help to a person it's when they know they're staying away from this they're only eating this certain food that has very little histamines on the histamine food list but they actually have antibodies to that food so every time they eat that food their body is baking histamines.
To deal with it so I know that sounds complicated but you know if you can understand that your body makes histamine and you you're not trying to stop your body from making histamine you're trying to go why is my body making histamine against food well it shouldn't unless you have an antibody against that food or a pathogen unless you have antibodies to that pathogen.
So for instance if a person has antibodies to a mosquito the pathogen the chemical in a mosquito bite they're not exposed to mosquitoes they don't have a histamine reaction the only happening when they're exposed to that chemical.